[Music]
albert
is in austin texas hey albert how are
you
i'm doing good how about you dave better
than i deserve what's up
so basically i have about 140 000
in student loan debt between me and my
wife we make about 140 grand a year
and we basically are in a position where
we can either
make monthly payments of 1400 a month
and pay off all our debt in 10 years
or we can enter into a repayment plan
put about the maximum into our 401ks and
essentially pay zero dollars for the
first five years
and then after 20 years potentially get
everything forgiven so i'm trying to see
whether we should just
start to pay it off completely or
whether the repayment plan could have
some
benefits that you know allow us to save
money and invest
earlier because you know compound
interest
what's your degree in so i have a
master's in finance and
my wife she has a bachelor's of science
in nursing
i saw that one coming um okay
albert um i don't know what uh
the greek word for irony is but i think
it's finance degree
oh in 140 000 well done man you're a
smart kid aren't you
well it most of it was actually for me
so before i got my master's degree
we had about 70 grand and then that
program cost about an extra 70 000
but it did increase my income by about
30
so i saw it as worth it so you increase
your debt load by 100
and your salary by 30.
yeah but the the amount of time it would
take to you know kind of
get that 30 increase in my regular
career which was i did a bachelor's in
accounting
where it took me about five years so i
saved five years
of time trying to move up the ladder by
just going to school one year
okay i i have a degree in finance as
well
and people that are wired like me
and you uh have a
tenant well you've ever you've always
heard that your greatest strength is
your greatest weakness right albert
yeah and my i have a couple of
tendencies because of my
um uncanny ability with math
i'm very good with math and you are too
i can tell because everything that
you've talked about since you got on the
phone
is all about mathematical analysis and
so
the uh and john's right you're obviously
a very bright guy
those things are actually going to work
against you in this conversation though
um and because they've worked against me
in my past
and so um being the old older nerd
of the two of us in this conversation um
i made the mistake of thinking that
i could measure all issues like risk
and strain and
relationship messes with a
math formula and you can't
and so for instance in the formula that
you just used to
justify your master's degree you did not
have anything
in that math formula for the extra risk
you took on
with a 70 000 extra weight
all you did was just look at a simple
roi
and so you left life variables
out of your formula called risk and
thereby would have neutralized some of
your mathematical
uh conclusions but you learn that after
risk
knocks your freaking teeth out a couple
of times and then you go
okay the math formula missed that and uh
that's what happened to me
so and has more than once and so
we need to do the best we can do with a
mathematical analysis but
what i'm going to urge you to do is to
realize earlier rather than later
because it hurt me i brought pain into
my life that math
uh does not measure common sense math
does not measure risk very often there's
a few places you can actually use
a beta an inverted formula and you know
what i'm talking about
on an investment albert but but there's
very few times that people
actually plug risk into these equations
uh which makes your which makes our math
naive
it's it's uh it's uh emotionally
immature
does that make any sense and so all of
all of that to say
no do not stay in debt
20 years and try to screw around
and get rich with your 401k while you do
three
versions of a two-step twirl around
hoping some political thing is going to
come along and
bail your butt out of this ridiculous
hole you dug yourself into
no you take your hundred and forty
thousand dollar income
and you punch this mess you made in the
mouth and you get rid of this student
loan as fast as you can
because all the data that we have on
millionaires says
that none of them not a single one and
as we studied 10
000 of them and this is statistically
significant
not a single one said i'm gonna keep my
student loan around as long as i can
and dance with it so that i can invest
in my 401k and it will offset
and i understand mathematically how you
got there but dude
naive doesn't even touch this
conversation
please set the pencil down
and go and just pay off your student
loan
get visceral emotional about it and get
rid of the mess
quit walking around proud about the fact
you've got it
it's a it's a mess now go
fix it here's what it looks like in real
life you got a wife it's a nurse albert
you
have a finance job as dave said there's
any sort of correction in the market and
they call you in because you're new and
you're young and you're gone
and suddenly your five-year acceleration
turns into a seven-year
deceleration that's number one right so
and you're gonna say that never happened
to me i got a graduate degree cool
live in that world step two is your wife
who's a nurse
after year seven says i cannot do this
anymore the secondary trauma is wearing
me out
or you have a kid and you end up with
twins and she says i want to stay home
or or or one of them has needs you are
yeah one of them's got special
you are hedging a 10-year bet and i
don't know if you know anything about
the last 10 years
i'm not betting nothing except the
the turtle's going to win every single
time and i'm going to take the
the the small stuff and the smart step
this is not a math problem it's a
psychology
don't try to spiritually trick life with
a mouse formula
you're going to get your face smacked
off don't do it pay it off three years
man three years
three years you need to be debt-free in
three years and then move on with your
life